quick question auntie yeah well yeah
well the show's going so far it's going
fine everything's great but I just had
this sort of crazy notion to try
something a little different I was
wondering Andy you want to go have some
summertime fun are you thinking what I'm
thinking
well that it's August right and and the
pool is heated up right and maybe it's
getting late in August and I don't know
I think maybe are you ready for some
summertime fun yes I'm wearing a bathing
suit underneath these pants that's
unbelievable
[Applause]
cuz guess what guess what so alive
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
take it from me if you're really hungry
in the middle of a show and you have
barely passable body doubles to shoot a
pool montage for you that means you have
time to dine here at Antonio's off to
the side on stage restaurant delicious
pasta comfy seats and the food is free
no any that the food isn't free I I'd
pay for it yeah you paid for it so to me
it's free Antonio's onstage Italian
restaurant it doesn't exist
[Applause]